[Aplausos]
o álbum
quantas vezes na vida você se permitiram
mudar a realidade de alguém que vocês
não conheciam
quantas pessoas que vocês não conheciam
que tiveram pelo menos um dia melhor
porque vocês existiram essas perguntas
me trouxeram até aqui hoje
nasci e cresci na zona leste de são
paulo próximo da região de itaquera na
minha infância eu tinha duas
preocupações
ir para a escola e ficar na rua
brincando com os meus amigos simples
como esconde bolinha de gude taco
em uma dessas tardes brincando com um
amigo kaká do nada correria barulho
confusão gente gritando a gente é o
correndo assustado sem entender e mais
tarde a gente descobriu um que o rapaz
tinha dado um tiro outro rapaz
naquele dia a gente presenciou a nossa
primeira cena de violência
na adolescência os meus amigos já não se
importavam mais com as brincadeiras que
durante tanto tempo nos divertiram essas
brincadeiras foram substituídas pelo
desejo de ostentar um tênis uma roupa de
marca poder status as festinhas
proibidas como os meus pais chamavam
ainda jovem e ouvir alguns dos meus
amigos entrando para o mundo do crime
e eu queria também continuando com eles
porque eles eram os meus amigos de
infância e eu tentava chegava nos meus
pais e falava mãe pai todo mundo da rua
vine essa festinha fulano vai o kaká vai
eu quero e também meus pais sempre me
respondiam com algo que muito
provavelmente quem é pai já falou e
tenha filho já escutou luís
você não é todo mundo
[Música]
repetindo essa frase eles não só me
protegeram dos riscos mas também me
ajudaram a construir a minha identidade
além disso os meus pais mesmo com as
condições financeiras não sendo muito
boa
ele sempre dava um jeito de ajudar
alguém e através disso também pôde
conferir os meus valores e isso sem
dúvida são os maiores privilégios que eu
tive na vida e por causa desses
privilégios e conseguiu ingressar em uma
universidade pública que não é pra vc
conseguiu estágio em uma grande
multinacional foi efetivado estava indo
bem e na minha cabeça dali pra frente
estava tudo certo
aquela vida padrão comprou um
apartamento em troca de carro todo ano
do sul na carreira de tiro férias no
exterior e quem sabe eu fico rico ao
mesmo tempo que estava crescendo na
minha carreira eu sempre recebi a
mensagem dos moleques lado da rua
em uma dessas mensagens me falaram que o
kaká é meu amigo de infância tinha sido
preso e aquilo mexeu comigo demais
porque a lembrança que eu tinha do kaká
eram as melhores a partir disso eu
comecei a me questionar por que que eu
estava com o pensamento são
individualistas numa sociedade que já
era tão desigual qualquer o meu papel no
mundo 1 mas os salários e benefícios que
eu tinha naquela empresa era um ótimo
então eu fingia que a vida é assim mesmo
estava tudo bem depois de um ano
o kaká me mandou uma mensagem estranhei
por carla luís irmão liberdade cantou tá
ligado
do souto velho agora eu consegui um
emprego aqui numa lojinha no braço
tomando com a minha filha com a minha
esposa tá tudo certo agora vou dar
orgulho para minha família
nós quando eu receber aquela mensagem
poucas vezes na minha vida eu fui tão
feliz tão completo tão preenchido como
naquele dia eu respondi kaká irmãos
orgulhoso de você cara tô feliz
é incrível e vai ter a chance de ver
suas filhas crescerem cara é isso que a
vida quer da gente é coragem vamos pra
cima tamo junto
vamos fazer o seguinte semana que vem eu
vou te encontrar
a gente vai conversar e eu quero que
você entra na faculdade que você tem que
fazer uma faculdade
eu estava muito feliz se estava
esperançoso
o kaká é poder ter acesso às coisas que
eu tive acesso e na semana que a gente
ia se encontrar mataram ao catar tiros e
aquilo e derruba acabou com a minha vida
[Música]
o no dia do velório eu só conseguia
chorar no colo da minha mãe já tinha
acontecido isso com alguns a um vizinho
conhecido mas o kaká eu não conseguia
acreditar num inventar uma desculpa
qualquer mas no fundo eu sabia que você
não sai do crime com a mesma facilidade
que você entre o que aconteceu com kaká
de certa forma eu deixei acontecer
a negligência ea sociedade negligência
né
eu fiquei tão focado e anestesiado nos
meus desejos individuais sim que eu
esqueci dos valores da identidade que
minha família me ajudou a criar
eu já me importava mais com o caminho
dos meus amigos estavam seguindo que
passar na rua do lado de uma pessoa que
está agonizando de dor de frio de fome
era normal e não deveria ser como se eu
tivesse colocado os valores individuais
acima dos valores humanos e não é legal
isso
[Música]
então eu precisava agir
precisava fazer alguma coisa já não
tinha mais vontade de levantar da cama
não tinha mais vontade de trabalhar e eu
inventei uma desculpa qualquer e pedir
demissão
e aí todo mundo fala que tá louco cara
todo mundo quer trabalhar nesta empresa
mas eu não era todo mundo ninguém
entende a dor que eu carregava era como
se aqueles tiros que acertaram o kaká
também tivesse me atingido mas não no
corpo físico na alma
no fundo eu tinha certeza do que eu
queria eu queria três coisas eu queria
que menos jovens precisava enterrar seus
filhos
eu queria que menos mães como eu queria
que menos mães precisassem enterrar seus
filhos
eu queria que menos jovens precisam ter
os seus amigos
eu queria que menos jovens precisassem
ser enterrados e eu sabia por
experiência própria e por influência da
minha família que a educação é o caminho
porque se um dia alguém tivesse falado
para os meus amigos que eles podiam
fazer uma faculdade
talvez eles estivessem aqui hoje me
prestigiando ou talvez no palco e se os
meus pais não tivessem insistentemente
falado pra mim que dava pra fazer uma
faculdade
[Música]
talvez eu não estivesse aqui hoje para
contar essa história pra vocês
juntei-me com um amigo diego e fundamos
a nokia educação um cursinho que prepara
jovens de comunidades escolas públicas
para ingressar nas universidades que já
impactou centenas de jovens nos locais
onde a gente atua são luís no maranhão
são sebastião santo andré mas mais do
que isso a nokia e me permitiu acessar o
meu potencial humano
dali pra frente eu comecei a enxergar as
pessoas que antes eu achava que eram
invisíveis
e que às vezes a gente ainda acha que é
invisível né
eu me permitir começar a ajudar essas
pessoas para que pelo menos um dia na
vida delas fosse melhor porque existe
uma coisa simples que eu estava num
evento de uma ong que eu sou voluntário
estava rolando um show lado um tal de
mmds que eu estava olhando moleque de
longe eu falei pô esse moleque é bom
cara e depois do show fiquei pra falar
com ele e falei para você é bom me
passou o contato quer saber mais de você
ele falou o caro acabei de sair da
fundação casa não tem o telefone pega o
contato com a minha mãe fala quiser
falar comigo você fala com ela que eu
peguei o contato foi embora mas aquele
jovem não saía da minha cabeça no outro
dia liguei pra falar com ele e falei
cara seguinte a fim de dar um show lá
para os alunos da noc bater um papo
agente remunera vamo ele foi e conforme
ia conversando com a galera com jovens e
conforme ele ia cantando eu ficava
deslumbrado com a habilidade que ele
tinha de inspirar os jovens com as
reflexões que ele gerava o evento foi
incrível passar o seu tempo o mds está
um pouco sumido
eu falei vou mandar uma mensagem para
ele no facebook ea idéia de como está a
vida na quebrada e tal e ele mandou na
lata sincero assim luís então o osso
passamos pelo agente financeiro que
agora voltei a fazer uma parada errada
eu não queria mas não tem jeito não é
isso que eu quero pra mim total difícil
e aí sem pensar ou responde cara faz o
seguinte pega suas roupas sim foi na
mala e venda pra minha casa vai passar
uns dias aqui comigo sem pensar
você vai ver como a nokia vai me
acompanhar as palestras vão embora e
depois de uns dias ele foi e aí nessa
versão dele lá em casa a gente dormindo
ou trocando idéia com ele tomando café
ou trocando idéia com ele
levei ele para a nokia livre nas escolas
públicas e lá nas escolas públicas
os jovens começaram a se identificar com
ele ele começou a perceber que ele tinha
um potencial de transformação dentro
dele
bem ele percebeu que a dor que ele tinha
também de ter perdido amigos e que a
história de superação dele poderia mudar
muitas vidas assim é a vida do décimo do
hoje ms pela educação têm emprego
registrado em uma família linda tac por
aí
e à pergunta que eu preciso responder
quantas pessoas sim
além do df vão viver melhor porque
existe que vocês sim quantas pessoas vão
viver melhor porque vocês assistiram o
mds pra mim foi uma segunda chance
eu não podia deixar acontecer novamente
o que aconteceu com tatá
eu aproveitei essa oportunidade e por eu
ter aproveitado o ds ganhou uma segunda
chance
porque se ele não tivesse ganhado ele
não poderia subir aqui neste palco hoje
obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]
johnson
olá eu sou jônatas
tenho 21 anos sou do extremo sul de
parelheiros e nem fosse foi como de
todas as crianças
jogava bola ficava de bolinha de gude
soltava pipa andava de bicicleta
só que é um dos meus 15 anos a minha
infância foi tomando a trajetória
diferente eu conhecia o crime e por
conhecer o crime
eu dei muito desgosto para a minha mãe e
fui preso
aos 15 anos foi uma das piores a foi uma
das piores coisas que podem acontecer na
minha vida foi o teu dado esse desgosto
pra minha mãe só que ao mesmo tempo eu
preso eu descobri que foi uma das
melhores porque lá dentro descobrir um
bom dentro de mim que era cm se o tempo
foi se passando obviamente foi formando
pensava que não queria mais desgosto
para minha mãe que eu queria sair de lá
de dentro que eu queria transformar em
uma liberdade chegou depois de um ano e
três graças a deus e só quem passou lá
por dentro sabe o valor da liberdade
sabe o que é sofrer de verdade mesmo não
poder tomar um sol na hora que você
quiser não poderá andar pra onde quiser
como o livre arbítrio sabendo que é o
certo o caminho certo e o caminho errado
e após eu ter saído de lá e me
transformando me conhecendo melhor
eu virei um homem de verdade
hoje eu sou pai tenho duas filhas têm um
serviço registrado na minha quebrada foi
convidado para ser líder de um projeto
de meninas que se chama pele feminina
que luta contra o contra o direito que
elas têm elas luta pelos direitos delas
na verdade ea e se esse projeto já
impacta mais de 40 jovens e meninas
junto hoje em dia e foi o poder de
transformação que houve dentro de mim
que eu tinha com os jovens e ao passar
do tempo lá dentro quando eu estava
fazendo minhas músicas nos momentos
vagos
eu fiz a música que eu tenho mais afeto
e carinho que a música da minha mãe e se
tudo hoje e
isso que vocês estão vendo aqui hoje
aqui em cima desse palco foi porque a
sociedade mudou a segunda chance e eu
não podia deixar escapar da minha mão
então espero que vocês gostem da música
obrigado a mostrar minha mãe pisada com
muito carinho amor mas assim ó olá
o ricardo pelo só seria de coração meu
filho sou de me mandou pra ser apenas em
voltar porque eles vão dar-me é nada sem
censura apenas no papel e xapuri
quando eu fui levar minha filha sempre
dita ter se irritado e monstro pra
senhora e assim 99 horas confiança eu
conheci várias moleque comércio de dar
trabalho veja quadro era o inverso dessa
vida lugar
eu me joguei copiar fuma absoluto para
já esse moleque era chamado de inss
composta e pouco na cinta ser herança
foi contra a senhora me via co
sei que o dinheiro ia cantando equipe ao
feriado que partilha a senhora percebeu
que não ia ter um bom que resolveu fim
mas a oit gana só seria estranho eu já
tava vendo os seus olhos ou inmetro que
já está com a senhora
agora acabou agora tudo mudou seu filho
não é mais tranqüilo o goleiro do le le
ei dólar eu amo vocês lá há há há há há
pra sempre mas eu te amo se conselho
fosse bom se isso que a senhora final do
dia foi ivete de s
cresceu ongoing perceber o braço armado
mas só quero um microfone popular samur
último ano
i walk militar montado que agora pensa
não me demonstrar meu amor para a
senhora do socorro se seu filho ou
reconhecido ontem recebi se foi agora
acabou
agora tudo mudou seu filho não é mais
contido o ele torcer e
ei dora eu não você lá há a praça irmã
dorothy amar
obrigado
[Aplausos]
no som
no fim das contas a única pergunta
liguei me enfiei e no fim das contas a
única pergunta que eu preciso responder
que a gente precisa responder na ds é
quantas pessoas vão viver melhor porque
nós existimos e vocês quantas pessoas
vão viver melhor porque vocês assistiram
quanto os ds estão lá fora só esperando
uma oportunidade no farol na rua é isso
obrigado
[Aplausos]